have you seen that on Twitter like
somebody with dick fighting oh actual
what actual people I were just on
Twitter one day and you saw two naked
dudes just hitting dicks yeah like not
two there were like so many I guess like
those are the final it's like a battle
royale hello everyone welcome back to
another episode of the trash taste
podcast I'm your host Joey and I'm with
the boys Garden Conner as usual and look
who's back on the trash taste podcast
it's it's been a while
so long I mean I think you were one of
the First episodes we ever recorded fth
episod episode and what are we on 170 5
176 now we we're into the fourth year of
trash tast now yeah it was just the
beginning of trash taste yeah like over
100 150 episodes later wow and people
still find me from trash T and like I
just watch your trash episode we now and
really W thank you hell yeah well I
think your episode is our most viewed
episode at this current time yes right
fix one is slowly climbing as I think
yeah for now you which is crazy not I
mean it's not surprising is cool seeing
that people are conly interested
especially in episode five of a show
that is going on for so long totally
hope this one will be VI keeping keeping
keeping I was just thinking that I
remember that that so I remember CU we
used to with every episode we recorded
we used to go out to an eai
afterwards you eat and drink and I
remember that's when you pitched to me
you were like hey we should we should
film this video doing like this latte
art yeah and I was like yeah I guess
so and then then we filmed that video
and then we've been doing videos ever
since which is crazy I know and my true
intention was to get here to be on a
Paul actually but I didn't want to Peach
like in a pole dancing remember that and
I actually thought about this be cool
you said Pawn for a
second what no that's the next year
St po dancing and I thought it would be
a good content but I didn't want to pach
that for the first time like it's like
it would be kind of weird I don't want
to come across the creepy I I think I
still probably would have done it I
think wait what I think back then I just
kind of started doing those T type
videos and started working together was
that before you did the first host club
video because I think I remember that
was after after and I wanted to do more
but it was really hard to find places
that were like really open to filming
and I guess you you were just really
good at like finding those convincing
them how how do you find all of these
weird places that you Pi sometimes I
don't know even I don't know how far you
like your contact I try to have like
what c f Japan kind of content and you
know like he's waiting the Conor is
still waiting to try anything the first
was try with like a cute why don't we to
make cute 3D L art and from there I was
like oh how about this and how about
that and of course I always like asking
beforehand of we always feel when like
get surprised and I kind of try to like
torture you but I always disg bur I mean
he is like a human like experiment like
he's like a hamster he's just down for
anything I think the people do these
weird things they got to have a reason
why they like doing it maybe if I do it
I can kind of find a little bit of the
reason why they like doing some of these
strange things and have you found that
reason or well listen if for the pole
dancing video If I had a body like SEMA
I'm sure I would be pole dancing sure
yeah that man was like like a Greek god
and then he would just hold his entire
body weight up with one hand and then
he's just ING with like really like
Attractive people men and women and I'm
sure it just seems really Funt and then
in the PO dancing place we go there and
then all these women and men are just
freaking out watching him and I'm like
yeah I think I get it like I get this
like I think I get it for him but for me
it is but he was so fun Simo was so fun
and eventually you're okay to do that on
the strip dancing that is by far the
most awkward thing I think I've ever
done in my life oh wow he's okay with
that yeah I cuz I remember that that
video so the premise was that Sima was
doing a show Sima is a pole dancing guy
I think he's also like he came like
third in the pole dancing World
Championship or something he's like one
of the best pole dancers in the world um
but just casually does these kind of
like yeah he Embraces his sexuality and
he puts together these like very
interesting shows that are kind of like
I I guess he just rents out a night club
mhm and then just kind of tells people
he's doing a show and then people just
turn up it's it's very odd
he wa is
coming like very like kind of I don't
know how to like not not scuff but it's
like it's kind of very like hey we're
just putting this thing together come on
show up yeah and I go to it and uh it
was just yeah he was very magic Mikey it
I felt like I was in like budget
Japanese magic M and he tried to teach
me this dance and I remember he was
teaching me this dance in like in like a
manga Cafe he's in this manga Cafe room
oh yeah internet cafe tiny room and he's
trying to do the dance moves but the
walls are too small I thinking like God
damn but scene was very funny so I I I
was like yeah it' be fun and then uh he
was the dis moment where I felt like oh
my God this is like at my limit of
cringe I can take is said he we we start
dancing and then he's like okay just run
up to someone and start grinding on them
I was like
dude and I remember I had to I had to do
it I felt so bad for you coo
I I had to awkwardly grind on you and I
was the whole time I was grinding on you
I was like I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so
sorry you were like it's okay it's okay
so that is the behind the scenes of
awkward hack yeah for sure so many
awkward so many awkward moments in so
many videos though that's how it goes
when you do these awkward stuff though
yeah but because you're okay with us
stripping like magic mic thing I was
like that's why I kind of said I was
like G to shoot that you know you you
talk about that on
trust I know that I said oh it's a term
Jose Yu in Japanese but the placea for
women to um you know get the sexual
crime act like happy
ending I thought it it's like a very
interesting I I check on the internet
like there was no single article in
English about that so I like oh wait
like this should be featured they should
talk about so I was like kind of
coordinating uh for an article and I was
coordinating with like a smaller
YouTuber I was like um he might be okay
because I didn't want to hide any cont
from you so I was like oh how about this
one he you thought about and I I knew
like it was too risky for big YouTubers
I spent 24 hours finger blasting
women I saw the video that you ended up
doing there uh and man it there was just
this one funny shot where I guess you
and uh Tristan are both just in the
corner watching this woman being just
watching and we're just
commentating we're trying to be quiet at
the same time like you know we can just
watch him we have stuck it's it's
YouTube it's like it's like silently
sitting with your best friend on a couch
watching porn together but like nothing
is happening you just watch it you
imagine it would be a very funny video
but I also would feel so bad if it I
came out kind of making fun of someone
who's just's like yeah I'll let you fil
me getting I mean that's kind of a
moment where you'd expect to be your
most like intimate and private
moment what did the woman like was she
okay with it like yeah she was tally F
think if she watch than what we saw on
the JB video yeah yeah totally yeah like
way more I just yeah it's it's I I don't
know I can't imagine cuz like yeah as
you were saying like it's like you know
in a private room right so you'd think
it's like you know I really want to get
intimate with this guy and I want to
feel good by the way don't mind the two
guys in the corner just like staring at
me just pretend they're not there it's
fine it's all POS act wor exactly just
pretend they're not there it's fine and
she was coming I I forgot that like I
don't know if I watched the entire video
but there are so many I a risky
content I think she got tied up like I
think it was shown in the video like
with like a red rope and yeah because
you'd pitch the placees me you like
Conor this is a place where you can get
a massage but they'll also help the
woman climax which is super vague
[Applause]
yeah but I mean as I I wanted to make a
video but I was like man I just don't
think I can think of anywhere I could
show anything right and know
monetization yeah yeah I think it'd be a
very funny 30 second shot in a video
about something else we're like and we
did this and then you're just like it's
me in the corner going oh God I mean
it's bang a patreon
Content imagine one person actually
coming in for a massage though and
you're like
wait where's the
climaxing I even like ask about legality
and yes if as long as they don't
penetrate it's fine like it's still
that's crazy I didn't know that in Japan
you can do everything but penetrate and
be you can pay for that yes like you can
actually have a business if you need a
permission for that but I mean I feel
like J Japan it's so well known and so
accessible I just
wonder why the hell haven't they just
tried to make some form of it legal and
make it more safe yeah it's it's well
it's another loophole in a loophole
right like gambling too yeah like
gambling Japanese businesses are very
good at finding the loopholes that you
can get away with legally I just I just
like to imagine it's just a bunch of
Japanese lawmakers who are just not
honest with themselves you know they
just like Oh No gambling is bad
prostitution is bad meanwhile in
secretly behind the corner they're like
[__] how do we make this legal without
making us look weird you know see it's
it's it's one of two options either they
like they genuinely just don't know
about it and it's just like a lot of
just like a lot of old people that are
just like out of touch with what's
really going on or they know about it
and they some percentage you know yeah
yeah right but yeah it reminds me cuz
like Sydney was telling me about this
place called it was like called like a
pink theater or something like that have
you heard about this yes pink Cinema I
guess pink Cinema yes I me you want do
you want to explain what it is it's
still like R8 like ad doubt film but
it's not AV is it right right see I I I
I was under the impression that it was a
place where you could watch r18 films
and people can go to these
Cinemas uh
and uh you know do the business they
need to do while the film is being
played acted out there's still a few of
them around I think yeah likeo or has
yeah I knowen has them I've heard about
this there just cinas where you just go
to jack off and like in back in those
days I was asked to story in those films
too of course the payment is just way
less and it's like a way lower budget
but still yeah how you been doing by the
way it's been so many years since we
were we were able to catch up you've
been doing a lot yeah you guys have been
a lot too look at all the March like you
guys
that this my new waiu cup actually drwn
by Gansu mangaka hya oku is so good yeah
I made like a proposal like I even like
made a PDF and kind of PowerPoint for
this teing because whenever I pitch the
Japanese artists they don't know about
waiu cops or apps so I make slides and
yeah commiss artist yeah yeah it's cool
right it's supposed to be me
that's that's so cool that
he you getting contact with him in the
first place I knew him before he
interviewed me once for his new work
well it finished but it's called Uh Gant
yes ganto he interviewed you for it yeah
like he needed to get some inside of the
actresses of that field yeah oh wow and
I did interview him for crol inter oh
okay okay yeah you I'm always surprised
at with the connections that you've made
over doing various different interesting
um and always endlessly fascinating yeah
thank you i' I've noticed you're going
to a lot more conventions in the US now
as well how's that going yeah it's been
great and I actually brought gamer to
Convention too because I thought they
would sell well they should have a boost
and they have been
successful we went to all Theon together
this summer and they said sales they I
think they got the highest sales like a
four a con on one day was not even
Saturday Dam thank you do you do you get
recognized over in America quite a lot
now yeah definitely and actually I got
like a younger and more like a female F
coming to my booth I guess to yeah
thanks to you guys thanks I think it's
more so thanks to you just making like
good content you know but I'm not sure
what the potential of female audience is
for trash taste but I don't think it's
rise off female audience let yourself be
known in the comments majority I think
it's pretty low yeah well most guys it
right now I'm I'm Vibe checking based on
the ratios of like most of our live
shows which I think is a good indicator
a good mix actually yeah sure but yeah I
guess online s is a bit more skewed yeah
and uh you also released your book as
well yeah English and Japanese right the
Japanese one came out quite a while
Japanese how how did the English uh
release go oh yeah I I think it's been
read a lot and like now that I can say
like whenever people want to ask me
about industry questions like oh you can
just buy my book and read stop asking me
questions buy the book it's all good I
love the difference between the Japanese
cover and the English cover it's very
funny how the Japanese one is just you
looking very like polite with text boom
boom boom and then English one and then
the English one is more like a little
Saucy it's just I guess it's the
difference between the two cultures man
you got to know how to pull the audience
right yeah all right I got I got the
male to female ratio uh past 365 days
what do you think take a guess I think
90% dudes 90% dudes 80% 80% what do you
think 75 84% male oh well that's not bad
84% which I is probably what I was
thinking to be honest makes how the age
took 20
years
F most of the 5y olds it's all
Kids 4 % 18 to 24 and 38% 25 to 34 wow
we have more we have more people between
the age of 45 and 54 who listen to us
then 13 to 17 good keep it that way yeah
let's keep it that way guys how was the
process of um translating your book from
Japanese to English because you wrote
the Japanese one and the English one
right well you had an editor helping you
with the English one because they wanted
to be more
sorrow Thor uh yeah cuz they needed to
like a pitch to The American audience
mainly and they wanted to be more aert
about a lot of things like one more like
from voyant and more like a typical you
know porn actes kind of talk okay what
what is the typical por actor sound like
well after reading the first draft my
managers who are uh they from United
States so they native speakers of
English and they told me that you sound
like a woman like wait older than your
age and who's holding a cigarette at a
bar and that's not you that's not so
they they also like you sound too
sophisticated to be AAR like you what
did they I mean use a lot of they try to
use a lot of F wordss and not I use FW
sometimes do you say I don't know yeah I
feel like you only being around you as
much as I have I feel like you only say
it as like a comedic thing you never say
say casually yeah yeah instead of saying
like damn and but they try to use it as
a Barb so often like instead of having
sex they trying to like a [__] like
okay so the one time when I was [__]
it's like I I think that's to do with
like just how people natively speak in
English like [__] is just such
a such a word that can be used with
almost like any context it means
anything and everything because I guess
when you're saying oh I [__] someone it
sounds so casual and nonchalant whereas
if you went into it more with a business
perspective and you're like I'm just
doing my job maybe maybe you're not like
I [__] him or I was having intercourse
with
like I just did I just clocked in bro I
just my 9 to5 yeah of course I'm not
going to say like I had a qu to it's
like Shon Cooper yeah who you who are
you at the same time I don't talk like
that in real exactly I wasn't trying to
but they're trying to I I've read some
like a feminism books in in carage so
they do use f word to describe sex
sometimes so right uh but I think it
more in a way to protest like oh this is
against our will so
was there any any kind of push back then
when you were trying to kind of make
sure it was the voice that you wanted to
present yes definitely it took longer
because of that battle like can I try to
make it sound more like myself yeah
right yeah and then even like the editor
said oh well if you try to you know talk
like anime princess like with high voice
like and then it's not going to sell to
the mass audience and I I I totally
hated the email after that after I never
talked to just like my I just met my
manager
talks yeah I don't even like name him
like I don't even like give a name to
him anymore after that I was like yeah I
even forgot his name but you know I just
call him did he actually in like he just
called you an anime princess and like
yeah the [__] what the
hell how have you how have you found the
difference between the reaction between
the Japanese audience and like the
english- speaking audience now that
you've released it oh yeah um no one
said they're shocked or anything I think
they're just finding it interest
interesting yeah and it's it's mainly
you discussing your work in the sexual
industry right yeah yeah well it's weird
that we've had two authors now on trash
days oh wow that's true I never want to
give Chris that credit oh okay I was
about to be like who's the other
one forgot yeah two reoccurring authors
now on trash taste God damn it now that
Chris is U what is it like a bestselling
author as well now I will never give him
the satisfaction of calling him an
author so guys please go by kaho's book
she needs to out
Chris we need someone to out we kind of
Chris being more of but speaking of
being anime princess like ever since the
first episode go first time I was here
uh I have been doing the anime judge of
crunch anime words so still this year I
just did my Paul I mean we are still the
round one process of trying to do the
nomination I just did that last night oh
damn nice oh for this year's CR roll
Awards oh nice 2024 oh and you spoil is
all but every year is different every
year their voting system changes or
judging system changes and last year uh
so last year they made it clear that
anything after October is not going to
be counted because it's just too soon
recy bias yeah right now we're filming
on October is it 15th um yeah like just
when we started nominating you a full
season starts so it's still fresh in
memory when and actual voting start but
it's kind of unfair to start judging I
guess that's why the Oscars wait till
like
February the full year can be done well
I remember the previous crunch R Awards
there were some awards where like a
season had not even finished before the
judging process started just because you
have to start it a little bit early but
December in December the previous the
fall anime season still hasn't ended yet
when you guys are co- streaming CR Man
Award it actually happened like you just
guys him won and you guys reaction was I
too soon instead of like yeah just SK
like feel like it's too soon that was
full animated maybe maybe I'm
controversial I just don't think fans
should be allowed to
vote I I think as fans and I'm speaking
as a fan myself we [__] suck at
voting like we we all like most fans
watch maximum like less than 10 anime a
year uh and so it's it's kind of then
unfair to go through all of this judging
process where I mean cuz you watch a lot
of anime feel you keep up with
everything uh and uh you go through this
careful process of of picking the
perfect nominations and then everyone's
like well I I I watched juu Ka this year
so I'm going to click all of that that's
the biggest difference right is that
like judges are looking at these shows
in a much more critical lens right
because they know that that's coming up
whereas like the average J kaen fan
isn't like looking at J kaon being like
well let's die SE as to why exactly is
the anime of the year like no this just
they [__] enjoying the show right so
obviously the reason why they do fan V
is because you get engagement on social
media website clicks and all this kind
of and fans get involved other I mean I
I think there is a good balance that
could be had uh because on the opposite
side of things now you have like the
Oscars which is the complete opposite of
this and it's it's getting better it's
getting better but they ALS since the
Chris Rock SLP you know that's start
coming back up that was the best content
but I feel every year they're also just
huffing more and more copi and being
like no no no we have to make it diverse
no more D no more diverse and it's like
all right just look just don't stop
thinking in The Meta game and just like
you know pick what you think was
actually good you cuz cuz cuz when you
have it to like a closed group of Judges
uh like the Oscars is it kind of becomes
just politics in the end totally and
it's you know you literally have films
being made that's the entire marketing
campaign it's just let's appeal to the
Oscars I would argue the value of the
Oscars is because it's so prestigious
because it isn't offend
if it was a fan it would be like [__]
Nickelodeon kid Cho I mean I feel like
the reason why it became so presious
because I mean the history of it but
because it's so it's like you're
appealing to certain people and and
you're kind of I don't know there's a
whole but I mean it's getting less and
less I guess important what do you think
about the game awards then because
Awards that's like fan voted but that's
like the very very small percentage
which I think they figed out I feel like
the game awards has got a great balance
the game awards I don't think anyone
ever the game awards thinking Man X andx
got robbed I think everyone I think a
lot of people last year are very happy
with how it all turned out you know um
it is what it is and for the nomination
process I try to actually pick names
like I try to have a variety just
because call it a nomination process
it's not judging no it's not voting
process voting is going to be popularity
contest no matter what so I try to name
so many shows like for each category I
want to name like different shows uh
then n year the
and of the Year kind of like got
nominated for like so many different
categories and I was like ah well I
couldn't help I got so I don't know how
many of your nomin like you did the
judging last year how many nominations
that you put down actually came up as
like the final nominations obviously you
can get some right you know you can get
some it's it's going to make it like you
know for sure like oh like a spy family
or that this year probably OKO is
definitely nominated for a lot of
categories they deserve that actually
but like sometime it's about Marketing
in the west like I was so disappointed
that I couldn't see summertime render in
not even like animation
Disney or Disney plus like oh wow it's
hasn't been noticed and yeah I I I think
the the problem is right now and because
I've been asked to be a crunch for judge
before and I just I just remember
thinking I don't like I don't know how I
come out of this with like being happy
you know
because because the problem the problem
is the problem is right now is that
there are just too much like anime even
for a judge to watch like like even even
I and I'm sure yourself we tried to
watch as much as possible but even so
there's probably some shows that people
have missed along the way like what do
you mean I can't nominate 50 ISO shows
like this is
[__] actually I just want one I just
want to nominate one at this point
that's that's all won but who W won best
fantasy [__] Demon Slayer won best
fantasy last year I'm not even joking
which is so
cap I feel like if I was the producer
and I saw that I would be like guys hit
me out how how about we [__] this thing
I'll just do a I'll do a Pro Gamer move
and change result they try to like have
different categories each year and this
year I thought it went a little bit
technical actually oh lately or I think
the understanding is if they have a good
sakuga like key art it's like know best
animation right usually you pick them
for best animation but this year they
added not just best animation but there
is like a best uh art Direction and best
cinematography
and oh well how do we differentiate yeah
technical the average anime F does not
know the difference they don't you know
you can't have like a best editing
category for fans cuz they don't [__]
pay attention [__] you know what I mean
like this is why in other things that's
you know you have that's not going to
make a difference they're still going to
vote [__] jit that's just that's just
two more awards for jiit KA like so
hopefully we see like different names
for each category proba yeah hopefully
you you can you can fancy it up but if
it's still like a fan vote it's still
always going to be skewed towards the
popular vote which I think even like
especially now in the anime Community
there has never been such a bigger gap
between let's say Shonen and everything
else you know like the popularity Gap is
like insane right now especially with
how big
like I I think one piece is getting
close to like mainstream now you know
it's getting close to that level of
popularity but like it's it's kind of
like the same level as like you know
back when Marvel and comic book started
to get popular it was like Marvel and
then every Indie comic like it made
Marvel more popular but every Indie
comic scene everything Comics outside of
just the big two was just like unheard
of you know forgotten yeah for sure what
uh What shows have you enjoyed this year
then that you have nominated I actually
U I been I decided to binge watch One
Piece from beginning this year and it's
wait what hold on I know he's taking
forever yeah no [__] it's like a
thousand
episod yeah because you know you start
watching like remember when w started
that was 25 years ago we were still
babies and you know we were still kids I
don't remember like watching everything
so I was like why do I start from the
beginning yeah but the first couple of
ARS are raw like it's it's hard to see
the first 200 chapters was it was tough
it was slow so I can't imagine watching
and I'm caught up on manga so at least
some part I can kind of skim through
like you know what's coming already and
it does get better animation wise like
from the end of hake Island and wuni
like the animation upgrade was insane
fantastic but that's like 700 uhep
they're going to they're going to remake
that anime one they're going to do the
hun hun treatment on
it yeah yeah because they be like guys
we can make free
money one piece two when is that coming
out two piece when two piece out exact
same thing but we cut out all the boring
[__] and make it cleaner yeah I me so
you've watched one piece and you've had
time to watch other anime this I'm
impressed with the amount of because I
remember the first time you came on the
podcast you you specifically said this
thing to me and I didn't understand what
you meant at the time cuz I didn't know
you well enough but you were like man I
just a lot of people like they say they
like anime and video games but they
don't really like that I didn't know
because I didn't know you then I didn't
realize what you meant but I was like oh
after spending more time with you and
and and like getting to know you more I
realized oh ok doesn't [__] around with
I some I watch [__] like oh my God this
just [__] the guy just wasted some time
of course I don't I don't know how you
do you spent all your time doing all
this stuff but you're also super
productive it seems because you're
always posting stuff and doing stuff but
you then you'll be like I just played
every single Yakuza game and and
I tried 100% one game and I'm still
regretting it I still want to do it it's
91% yeah that's going to it's going to
take you an extra 100 hours to get that
9 I put like more than 200 hours yeah
you also sleep either like 1 hour or
like 15 hours a day right I can never
tell yeah like I love sleeping like I
can just sleep for more than 10 hours
like a pregnant lady like I can do that
all day serly every day uh well I don't
really go out so yeah I watch anime when
I eat you know that Mak yeah yeah well
what have what have you been watching
that you've enjoyed then oh yeah also oh
again another bch watch but I've been
trying to get into like a power engine
also toy do you remember the toy version
I mean nobody remembers nobody was worn
but back Dan about toy version of
Spider-Man yes CPS of that I really
enjoyed watching it's like super STI but
like SP that's like the beginning of
Super Sentai so not only do you have
enough time to rewatch one piece watch
all these new shows but now you're
watching to satu [__] as well like how I
know it's so hard to keep
up cuz we'll get do the video shoots and
I'll be like all we're going to meet up
at 8 and K would turn up like dead like
I had two hours I'm like what like yeah
I don't know I was playing
games godam I wish I could still live
that life yeah right yeah I don't
dermatologist more
often cleared up your skin Kong get old
if you don't leave the house and never
go in the sun right that is true by the
way your skin looks great today thank
you I been moisturizing more
often told skincare routine now well I
just moisturize which apparently is well
that's a skincare routine it helps yeah
apparently uh I didn't know this you
should just wear sunscreen every day
yeah did you know this I did not know
that I'm white so first of all it
matters more well because like isn't it
like on cloudy days or overcast days the
UV is actually stronger than on a sunny
day you just need to look at the app UV
that day and if it's like over like a
three well why do you think all these
like you know older women wearing those
like sleeve things like I umbrellas I I
have no shame I just I you do in the
summer yeah cuz it's I I get cooked and
I I burn so I was like man I should
probably start moisturizing CU I already
L like 50 and
I I should probably start taking care of
myself I started doing the the Mudan
Strat as well I'm taking vitamins you
doing the vitamins now I want to see if
they he influenc you he influenced me I
want to see if they work my editor mood
antique 27 pills in like 27 something
ridic 12 way too many wow well he's very
fair so sense you didn't do the health
exam before I didn't I'm taking an Allin
one cuz I figured ah why not let let's
get them all so uh we'll see if it helps
I'll I'll update you guys in a few
months nice this is like the future
you're just like you're just eating
pills at the end yeah trying to trying
to be healthy but it's it's so hard yeah
when you're [__] sit at your desk all
day and then and then if not I'm
traveling and then when I'm traveling I
eat really badly drink a lot and all
that kind of [__] yeah is like let's go
and do a giant eating
challenge it's just visually nice it is
visually is visually impressive for sure
I think I'm think I'm done with the
eating challenge I think just after
doing one I don't know my my mind is not
as strong as my stomach is a lot of the
times and seeing you guys do it I like
it knocks me out for just 2 days I it's
like it's like you're eating like 3
4,000 calories you got you down the most
most eating challenges I guess yeah like
Chris and I have done what four now I
disg yeah that one was [__] I did one
with Connor the spiciest Ramen one that
was at least kind of nice yeah I mean I
was tasted good yeah I was in so much
pain afterwards like I've I've I've I
figured it out now I've I told Chris
this and I'm like we we're going to keep
doing these like eating challenges just
cuz there's so many of them in Japan but
we're doing it once a year because any
more than that I am going to die at
40 it's just not healthy at all and
sometimes you know what it's not worth
the views sorry n avocado I don't
understand your mentality around that
but I just can't do it the your Bor
system or it's just it's just like I
don't know you you finished the meal and
even if yeah even if the meal was like
kind of delicious like at the beginning
or whatever like just by the end of it
you just want to
die and I'm just like I know yeah and I
was like I know this one meal has just
aged me 5 years you know and I just
don't have the mentality to be like yeah
let's keep doing this you know to get
the clicks so yeah next next one will be
next year with something I don't know
I've noticed you've been streaming more
often as well oh yeah I've been doing it
for fun but just yeah it's fun really
it's for fun I don't really consider
myself a streamer sometime I just tell
people I'm streamer you know just you
know same here you know just like it's
just like depending on the yeah at least
at least you fully committed to it now
you fully have like transferred I I got
hours I got a clock in and out I got to
do I got to stream x amount of hours
every month oh so I guess it's full-time
I just set myself up to a full-time job
fair enough on top of everything else
you're doing yeah yeah so fun fun that's
fine though it's nice this episode is
sponsored by boxu boxu delivers the
experience of tasting authentic Japanese
snacks candies and tea sauce directly
from centuries old small family
businesses right to your door their
mission is to empower Japan's
traditional snack makers by sharing
their authentic food and stories with
the world the first Boxer you'll receive
is called The Seasons of Japan following
the Season of Japan you'll receive a new
monthly theme box like this one this
month the theme is AA tea time oh God it
seems like you have some Hut tea latte
right roasted green tea we've got
something beautiful here Joey what is
this right here that I'm holding that is
star of nigata amakara rice I'm going to
give it a try right now that looks like
a you snack ooh that smells good that's
a thick boy that is a thick boy oh it's
good that look at this look at these oh
those look good those are some uh scones
not the bread type of scones but the
little snacky type scones oh the smell
this is spice curry flavor oh I got
tries spice
curry that's so good M that's really
good and guys to get $15 off your own
boxu Japanese snackbox and supporting
the channel in the process you can use
our code trashtaste boxer.com that's b o
k
ks.com that is bk.com with code
trashtaste for $15 off your first order
back to the episode oh yeah I'm doing
voice acting for new anime but it's
obscure anime but oh [__] oh you are yes
oh hell yeah what anime youing in
ah from January so yeah okay yeah like a
small role or yeah one of the main girls
it's like a har show oh [__] hell yeah
it's like I don't know if you know the
category about Saku like Mon oh oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh you do yeah wait
what is it it's it's like a monk how do
you explain it yeah it's
like wait is this one one where the monk
like has a bunch of girls chasing after
him and he's like temp oh it's different
yeah yeah that's yeah I think I think
that's a different one yeah they have t
and they're based on comic books all the
time kind of like a h manga didn't you
you told last time you came on you said
you voice that in a hentai did that end
up coming out oh yeah I have no
idea it's just so small just so small
but this time like I'm heav involved in
the pr process okay nice ni yeah yeah
one thing I wanted to ask about since we
touched on streaming earlier was I I
mean Conor made a video about this
before and this was like a while ago um
but it was like to do with the topic of
like stream sniping and oh god oh yeah
and like since I since now you've like
put yourself out there you know in like
kind of like the IRL space a bit more
often now what was like what was that
experience like what what exactly
happened to you uh with like the stream
sniping and I I heard you got followed
or something like that or people waited
waited for you he waited I mean was it
just one person or it was one person
yeah and something like that not even
before streaming happened to me when I
go to event and try to I saw I can
handle myself but then there was
somebody waiting for me like at the
entrance or at the exit and sometime I
just noticed and I try to hide in
bathroom for a long time right and yeah
that things happen when you're
completely by yourself so I just stop
doing that don't do that [__] all right
to anyone did you find it like got worse
as you like became an IRL streamer or
was it like worse before when you were
doing doing your previous jobs I
actually assumed worse uh when it comes
to I streaming I was kind of afraid of
doing it in at first yeah um but be if
I'm streaming it's fine because it's
like evidence you know you are the
protector like got you
[__] some people Cameran never does
that's the way it works yeah some people
try to wait like until I finish and try
to catch me that happened like twice and
I like if they did that on camera I
could probably yeah it's not as scary do
you think maybe because like the kind of
IRL I guess atmosphere or like the vibe
of doing IRL stuff like doesn't
necessarily like incourage that behavior
but it slightly like normalizes that
behavior to be like oh well you know I'm
just a fan and I wanted to come on to
stream and just hang out and stuff like
that like do you think that might be the
case Roby yeah like sometimes like
people ask me oh can I get your line
number or line is an F like chatting app
in Japan that's not even being subtle
like that's that is the equivalent to
like asking someone for that number and
yeah it's like your line is kind of like
your personal phone number yeah I guess
when you're streaming especially in IRL
you kind of become a friend and it's
easier to have like a social what what's
that social what's that I forgot the
name
social that's a new word they see you
like living your normal life da stuff
yeah just because they make it humanizes
you you know yeah it humbles yeah the
beauty of ir streaming is you can enjoy
like going to Tokyo like vicariously
through the streamer so I understand
that you kind of feel closer to streamer
but you have to give them some space I'd
like to get your opinion on this because
I I don't think it's just like the IRL
space but Al also in like the Ado
industry as well you know I I think
recently we've had a huge rise in like
only fans and like let's say independent
adult workers as opposed to being you
know what you experienced when you
signed up by a company what's your like
opinion of the modern kind of like adult
industry and like the entire landscape
now I guess that system probably doesn't
really work in Japan because like it's
agencies they got big Power in Japan
take like more than 50% and that's kind
of if it's 50% that's usually like a
reasonable in Japan oh my [__] up I
know right so the for individual to get
stronger is fine but yeah to have like a
professional filming might be tough
until like you become really famous and
then become freelancer like some like
famous v v like a famous voice actors
they do the same
like because he has to be in Union so
yeah there's no way these like agencies
are going to be looking at all this
money or racking on only fans being like
what do you mean we don't get any of it
yeah [__] I mean yeah I think it's
kind of healthy that I think only F you
have to go is has to go straight to you
right has be indiv visual account so
yeah uh do you said you don't think only
fans would work for Japan is that is
that right yeah because agencies want to
take money and that's the system like
that's how ad industry kind of works
right definitely going to like see like
a really like popular only fans go and
then the agency is just going to swoop
in try and sweet talk them into like
probably joining that agency and then
you know rob their money for all it's
worth you know this is usually how it
works yeah because I you know I think it
it's good because it brings power to the
individual person definitely but do you
think like the agencies here have way
too much power for that to work I think
so and they want you know what are they
going to do instead
right they could probably be like I
don't know Ed
I don't know how yeah I guess you have
to give them some roles instead yeah I
heard some agencies some just also kept
the money like just didn't pay out I
heard that that's pretty it happens or
like they would give them they'd pay
them out but maybe the amount they were
paying them wasn't as much as they
should have been paid it's very weird I
mean it kind of sucks the money has to
go through the agent a lot of the time
so they get to be freers they just have
the presentent half the money anyway if
you if they know that you're freelancer
they're not going to pay pay you the
same amount like they just give you the
half because that's enough because
otherwise you just get the same amount
anyway so yeah I just think as well like
maybe I don't know this is from how I
see it maybe but like compared to the
West I feel like a lot of Japanese like
people especially like young people like
I don't think they understand maybe the
importance of like entrepreneurship as
much as like Western people like they
don't see it as a viable option I think
like they they probably see it as like
more of a pipe dream whereas like I
think a lot of people just think to
themselves I mean I could take the hard
route and you know pursue
entrepreneurship and re reap all the
benefits for myself but it's way easier
for me to just join an agency and just
sacrifice some of the money you know I
think Japan will get there I think Japan
will get there for sure I think there is
I I think companies in Japan have been
generally have been very solid for a
very long time so people have no reason
not to go independently cuz if you were
part of a company they would take care
of you but I think as as the Modern Age
we're seeing Japan's kind of struggling
a bit and I think also it's not going as
well and companies are letting go of
people I think in Japan as well like the
the whole like name value thing to a
company is so much more important
than the Johnny thing yeah like Johnny
for instance right it's like people are
still [__] signing off for Johnny's
even after all this [__] explain what
Johnny is too so yeah so Johnny is like
this massive like one of the biggest
Idol uh agencies boy Idol agency in
Japan that's been around since like what
this probably recognized in English now
because of that well the infamous it's
horrible horrible incident uh by uh
somebody who already passed away but he
was a CEO like a top person the found he
was Johnny yeah cool Johnny right yeah
so the company name is Johnny's Mr
Johnny Mr Johnny yeah so he was like
after he passed away there was a bunch
of [__] that was revealed that he was
doing a lot of like sexual misconduct on
younger boys hundreds though it was like
there was more and more keep coming
because now that they can say because he
was so strong he was so powerful if you
voice that you know you're not going to
be hard so what is he going to do he's
already dead yeah so now they're coming
out about it but like that's the thing
like the the but even after all of that
news went public in Japan the just the
pure name value and the fact that for
the longest time Johnny was like the
gateway to getting into the male Idol
industry people are still like joining
Johnny's to hopefully become a male Idol
because they're like well this is the
thing I need to do that PR was such a
nightmare they changed the name to smile
up smile up how can you
smile I can't imagine you just have all
of this horrible [__] happen you're like
guys we should name it to smile cuz
we're on the smile we need smile what we
need right now is smile we need right
now well I heard as well again I this is
all what a anecdotal but I heard that
the agencies generally are very powerful
in Japan because you know if the uh the
the TV or whatever any anyone who needs
Talent deals right yeah they like oh if
you don't do what the agency asks a lot
of the time they like well no talent for
you to work with on your variety shows
or no Talent when I was in the industry
like any adult professional girls uh if
they want to make more money they have
to do kind of shady work like Papa KATU
you know it's really criminal but they
try to make it sound you explain what
papat is so it's basically like a
prostitution
yes but instead of doing professionally
you just I don't know find somebody on
the Internet or you you know somebody
who knows somebody and yeah if you sleep
with them I guess you good basically
it's basically sugar daddy daddy could
use your sugar daddy this rich guy for
us and we'll take we'll take 50% the the
crazy thing is not just actresses but
it's been kind of popular things to do
for the colage students or who want to
pay tuition or maybe want some Gucci bag
or something I mean if it's consensual
and the person has decided and then they
they both want to do it but if an agent
is pushing you into it I think okay what
the [__] is going on here what the hell
yeah that's pretty [__] up if agencies
get into they definitely get arrested
because you're not supposed to of course
but if it's just individual I guess like
like you said you're not going to get
arrested you might get I don't know is
is it kind of weird yeah but hey [__] it
if you're not hurting any things could
go south very quickly in situations like
that you know so it's always scary to do
well it makes me wonder if there is an
interest from a Japanese audience
because like for from like a western
perspective it almost feels like if a
person was with an agency then you know
they're they're part of the corporation
you know but if there's if they have
like if they're an independent whatever
content creator whatever even if it's
like whatever industry they're in it
almost feels more like intimate you know
it almost feels like oh yeah you you get
to actually support this person directly
and I'm not sure if there's just a
different mentality with Japanese
audiences especially with you know the
Alo industry and the idol industry I I'm
not too sure I still I don't think they
look that deeply into that kind of stuff
like maybe you know maybe like fans of
like you know idols and stuff like that
look at like say someone who is in
Johnny's and someone else who is
independent and they probably know that
there's a difference but I don't think
they're letting that purely dictate
whether I should be more parasocial with
one or the other they find out like you
are me the streamer or the idol is
dating somebody that changes different
oh ageny or not your fult especially
with girl I guess especially with the
female Idol like oh now you got a boy so
maybe you don't need my support like you
get financial supported by your boy
anyway like that's kind of mentality the
wildest Story I Heard recently was the
story about the Japanese weather woman
oh yeah the P
player which like you know Idols I can
understand but like the fact that this
the fact that this extended to a weather
girl which yeah it sounds weird when you
say weather girl but then when you when
you hear more about the story you're
like oh no no they weren't making
weather girls they were making Idols in
to tell you the weather yeah yeah it's
like she cosplays she tells the weather
it should have been me godamn
it
also of course really oh well you know
of course na knows na like Na's got too
much
information she is she is yeah she was
the her fans were just more devastated
because I think she was not praying I
don't know how genuine her talk was
about it CU she's not finding anybody or
she's completely alone she doesn't get a
boy and turns out she do get a boy yeah
I mean it was it's so weird that you
know they they've tried to promote I
guess I I don't know I don't know if
they were really trying to make a
Weather Channel or if they trying to
make something else but uh I mean
whatever it was it [__] worked yeah
listen I I don't know any other weather
channels that sell merchandise of the
weather woman all right oh I saw the
weather woman on somebody's itach
oh wow yeah so so if you don't know the
full story I I believe this like Channel
I don't know if it's like a News Channel
or the whole network but they made it's
a 24-hour News Channel yeah okay it's a
24-hour News Channel they made a group
of women be like weather girls and uh
that's how they kind of like promoted
the weather I guess half the time half
the time it would kind of be almost like
a podcast radio show where like she
would like read like letters that she
received from like fans or like people
who watch the show just like people out
and about being like Oh today I really
enjoyed the weather you know all thanks
to you telling me about it by the way
thank you you know and and like she
would just kind of like talk about it
you know in between like the the hourly
weather updates or whatever it was and I
think like the way that that show was
structured just made it like parasocial
bait like to the point where it's like
oh she's cute and I get a chance for her
to read my letter yeah like that's that
means I'm in yeah and the fact that they
had like meet and greets and all that
[__] go to conventions and stuff yeah go
to conventions and uh you know yeah sell
out shows that's each country has their
own appeal of weather people you know
Japan has cute idols and I think
Colombia when you see their weather
women you're like oh oh this is very
different yeah and then in the UK we
have just 60 yearold men or women who
are like it's raining
again WEA girl tend to kind of say so
look like oh she's like completely
looking like a 20 years old barin but
but I think that's why yeah I think
that's why like when it was reveal that
she was in a relationship everyone was
just like what do you mean she's not a
virgin sheing with somebody what the
[__] very successful in Gooding I love
the I just love the entire Arc of how
like fans found out so so I believe the
entire Arc was uh she was taking some
time off work and people would thought
oh why why is she so like why is she
taking this much time off work people
don't take time off work yeah yeah and
so they thought she must have been going
going on a holiday or something like
that but she was I guess like she was
seene on television in England in Wim
she was yeah she was in the the seats
that are Norm reserve for family or
friends all the players yeah and there
was one Japanese player there and he she
was in the friends and family seats of
wi and everyone's just like no no no
maybe she's a friend of a friend who
knows the girl
person maybe she's related to the tennis
I don't know sh the deal was her mom was
there with her like oh no no why would
her mom there for
no sense imagine imagine being the fan
who just happened to [__] tune into
that Wimbledon match like not expecting
anything just be like you know what I I
just want to support my boy you know
let's go Japan pans over and just you
get your heart broken it's like what the
[__] I wasn't expecting this today I'll
never watch another weather forecast
again never watching tennis again I have
very vague general question um in your
in your like uh opinion or perspective
how do you think like Japan itself has
like changed in like the past 10 years
do do you feel like anything a very vain
question South is in like have you
noticed any changes in like the past 10
years in any anything
anything 10 years well well I I just
thought about a Twitter becoming experts
it's not really in Japan Twitter is more
popular in Japan than in the states so
oh really yeah it is I think more people
use Twitter okay okay yeah in 10 e well
the streaming is not well are these like
twitch wise and twitch is still not in
not known in Japan that much it's crazy
because some of the biggest uh streamers
on Twitch are Japanese I know well I
think especially like vtubers they
stream mainly on YouTube and yeah and
the streaming culture or the Tipping
culture or supporting the streamer
Financial culture is not there in Japan
yeah it's still rooted in like the Nik n
ER they buy a lot of merch though right
I think so yeah like they probably come
to meet and greed and a support like in
person it's more about meeting in person
because Japan is well is like smaller
like it's like it's big country but you
know easier to the side is Big yeah side
is like small and yeah I guess it's more
meeting the person and there are a lot
of like a Gamers who've been like
watching with so many viewers but like
almost like a zero sub so that I guess
like the streaming culture might be like
so different in Japan I see a lot of
vtubers ad aded just very small Indie
YouTubers just advertised everywhere I
would be passing a bar and they'll be
like this is our vtuber mascot for the
bar and I'm like what the hell cuz there
now there's like a billion vtuber
agencies you know whereas like 10 years
ago there was maybe like one maybe two
that were like kind of notable but even
then it's like now it's just like oh do
you want to be famous on the internet be
a vtuber well I guess cuz everyone
thinks that it's probably easy to make
money but I think being an agency it's
actually really hard to make money well
it's also I think just driven by the
fact that you know I think the majority
of people who do want to like start
streaming in Japan you know a lot of
them don't want to reveal what they look
like or you know their name or anything
like that so like the most common route
for that would just be Ving you know
which makes a lot of sense but at the
same time now all these agencies are
aware of that and so they're just going
to start exploiting the [__] out of
these people who don't know any better
yeah so that's one thing that's changed
guess higher rate of exploitation the
one thing that's really unique about um
V2 beer and the agency dynamic is that
now at least when you were a solo person
and you were a part of an agency yeah
they couldn't own you they can own you
now which is like the best thing that's
ever happened for agencies ever and the
worst thing that's ever
happened yeah the fact that you can just
own this character and all their socials
and everything is like I don't think
people understand how [__] awful this
is for creators and people who make
things or any artist out there this is
terrible this is awful aw
you don't have ownership for anything
but your voice yeah which is crazy and
even that like they you know the fact
that you can have the voice but you can
be deplatformed and lose everything it's
like
okay good thanks for nothing it's like
you're the mask singer but when you get
taken off they don't rip your mask off
they just kick you off stage it's like
actually know you never get to find out
who it was uh yeah maybe maybe he'll be
on Twitter somewhere else yeah you find
out I'm I'm just I'm just waiting for
like the time when they just get like an
AI program to replace your voice after
you decide to quit just like zie this is
100% going to happen uh I mean they
already tried to keep kizna ey alive
from the dead yeah like with 15 attempts
they were like please which which
homunculus experiment will work let's
find another voice actor and I figure it
out it's like if anyone doesn't think
this is going to be abused at some point
I think they're just dumb yeah
definitely at some point some agency is
going to figure it out and some point
it'll work it'll work at some point yeah
did you see K I actually made like or
her agency made an anime as well
and no was it was it was awful really
wow wait was it like was it an anime
around kids in the ey or just completely
separate no it was it was an anime
around they made like a kind of like a
vtuber agency anime oh is it like dis
year anime like original anime yeah
something yeah yeah and uh so so I
thought he had a lot a lot of potential
like an anime based around a vtuber
agency around like training vtubers um
made by vtuber agency you know I thought
there would there was so many different
directions this could go I forgot I
forgot what the name of it is but it
just turned out to be like a normal ass
Idol anime where
people they they just made another idle
anime and the best looking part of that
show was when K I made like a twom
minute Cameo uh two minutes just two
minutes okay just a two minute came
entire yeah in the in the entire show
wow yeah damn um but I'm surprised like
he his here's like here's like the uh
five head move I thought they were going
to do I thought they were going to make
an anime showing off these like new
characters introducing them to this like
Idol show and then debut them you know
that would have been the smart decision
no we just have like at this time a
below another below average Idol anime
least of the world yeah do you like Idol
anime at all oh yes I am actually I am
voicing this new anime but it's it's
going to be in January oh yes and then
actually it's the show in sodio like a
monk what's that monk time it's going
monk time it's like it's like Snot for
monk time like it's like a different
show but they're all based on TL or BL
or kind of like ichim manga right right
um well I am like one of the main girls
and actually I've been not just voice
but also doing the Ste song and doing a
lot of PE the P work too yeah I'm doing
like a Valentine's Day like chocolate
like handing out event to and met books
in February but so that's like a proper
idol God damn but the thing about those
shows like sometimes you can see like
they're going to be on TV but they show
the first part or like non Eder on TV
and if you want to see more subscription
side or buy the Blu-ray yeah Blu-ray DD
and for AER sometime they replace the
voice actors because some vas are but
they are too mainstream and they don't
want to risk their reputation
or sometime they have like a different
name and show up part but I guess you
know I don't care so that's I I can get
been there done that good I can show my
safe face you know this episode is
sponsored by Harry's guys there is a
subscription for absolutely everything
now from Artis jerky to all those
streaming subscriptions it feels like
we've lost their real value which is
saving time and money sometimes I don't
know which subscriptions I actually need
I can tell you right now now gone
especially for the gentleman out there a
subscription that you definitely do need
for yourself is a subscription to
Harry's with Harry's you get high
quality German engineered blades right
to your door every order saves you money
compared to that Big Brand most guys are
used to buying you can get this get them
for as low as $2 per blade but only by
going to harry's.com traste as you all
know I've been a simp for Harry's for a
very long time now I pretty much only
shave with Harry's because after
switching to the Harry's blade I found
out that the shave was just the cleanest
I'd ever had I'm not exaggerating there
is truth and uh ever since I've only
used Harry's and I really lament when I
have to use any other brand one of the
talking points they often tell us uh to
talk about is that how good the blades
last and I can I can tell you this uh
they last and I often find myself kind
of being like is it really done shave oh
okay it's not all I can keep going if
you go to harris.com trashtaste then you
can get the trial set which is a $13
value but if you use our link you can
get it for just $3 doesn't make any
sense it includes a five blade German
engineered razor weighted handle phone
in gel and a travel cover plus you can
schedule delivery for refills again for
as low as $2 half of what you pay for
other point C go and get a subscription
that saves you time and money with
Harry's get started with a $13 trial set
for just $3 at harry.com trashtaste
that's harry's.com trashtaste for a $3
trial set back to the episode well I've
noticed the line of for ety in anime has
been pushed more and more every year to
the point where I'm like what is the
difference between anime and like or ety
anime and henai now
true yeah I mean seeing something like
redo of healer I'm like this line is
obliterating there is no line this this
is just straight up that's why that's
why it was insane to watch I was like
okay I knew cuz like I knew a lot of
these scenes beforehand cuz I read the
light novel beforehand so I was like I
was waiting for it and then I guess what
I had watched originally was the like
the TV sensored version right so when I
watched episode to I was like why is it
just slowly panning on a fireplace for
15 minutes the wall like what's
happening and then I found doubt about I
was like all right let's actually check
this out and I I knew what was coming up
I didn't actually think they were going
to do it though you know even though
this is like the streaming Blu-ray
version I was like oh this is just this
is just hentai now it's crazy that the
the audacity for them to be like yes
this is an anime I'm like no it's not I
know I think in some ways it was like
worse than some of the henes I've seen
as well you know it's it it went in hard
like it it it it pulled no punches I
will never forget that dick slap scene I
will I will that is ingrained into my
mind for I could watch all the [__] up
haai in the world but the one that will
always sneck out to me is that [__]
dick slap in the face have you seen that
on Twitter like somebody with dick
fighting I don't know for the content or
like actual thing the uh the DI fight
island is that what it's called no it's
actually people no live action not anime
actual actual people and wait like [__]
fighting yeah [__] fighting yeah like
it's not Japanese it was I don't know if
when when or yeah where it was filmed
but wait wait you're going have to
explain this you were just on Twitter
one day and you showed two naked dudes
just hitting dicks yeah like not two
there were like so many I guess like
those are the final it's like a battle
royale yeah it's like a dancing
competition and Street dancing
competition and other like poor losers
were just chanting like go go go and you
was you have to show me this this is a
fever dream dancing
what I saying so crotch fighting oh my
you have to press it you have to press
it it's on it's like Central oh yeah
it's a comedy central show float like a
butterfly sting like a penis that's the
long and short of it the game is simple
it's the best of five rounds the fighter
with the most hits wins and the winner
is chub Norris it's like a joke it's
like a okay oh okay okay okay oh okay
it's a skit but on Twitter you don't
know like if it's real or not so like is
it happening cuz how can you stay hard
like know when yeah you were seeing this
going to be on Netflix or yeah I guess
you like if you're a straight o gate
that's going to be like a requirement
right so it's like wow what's going I
kind of want to watch
this like the under under like 21s they
got the they got the gay category yeah
they have to they have to otherwise it's
unfair
right it's unfair like legs yeah my
referee chat no checking in if they're
not hiding anything under
there that's actually kind of funny damn
they got to make that a real show I
would watch it I'm surprised that it
isn't already yeah right that was a very
random thing
to that's the sing of
Twitter keep coming
upz Twitter is [__] Twitter
recommendations be like
no it's some CCTV footage you didn't ask
for I get that every [__] morning I
look at Twitter it's just like I don't
I'm not even following this account why
why am I getting these I I don't want to
watch a dude getting hit by a car at 8
in the morning that's just not how I
want to start the day what it's horrible
what are
you dude there's this [__] there's
there's multiple accounts I get I don't
follow any of them right but every time
I'm on I'm on Twitter in the morning I'm
like I just want to see like what my
friends are up to this morning and I
check first thing or first or second
thing that always comes up is this just
like these [__] accounts that have
these like CCTV footage it's literally
just like Liv Le light that's
essentially what it is and it's just
like oh yes a man narrowly escapes
getting hit by a train and I'm just like
cool but I just woke up I don't I I
don't want to watch any of this my T is
just a mix between news and boobs so
it's like like it's like one one one
news opposite yeah it's horrible cuz
I'll be scrolling and I'm like man this
news nothing in between news so boobs
yeah well it's man I think that's
Twitter mostly I see like news it be
super depressing like 10 people die and
then you scroll down you're like Bo [__]
you're like can I see more news Bo
please M mine are just like
controversial takes boobs controversial
takes about anime boobs anime boo yeah
yeah
yeah always theime it's always the anime
boo because I follow Joey that's the
reason why yeah
nice but uh do you have any upcoming
plans or any projects that you excited
for actually I'm becoming a game
character too I me I'm game characters
what aren't you doing Jesus you're doing
everything well under N I cannot talk
about details yet but uh I up beat them
up that's my favorite gen oh you're
always playing beat them up yes and I'm
going to be beat him up character and I
was like I want this is going to be a
DLC character so like I'm going to be I
have to be stronger right than the main
characters right and I want to have a
unique weapon and I thought about I want
to fight with
bread so with bread bread yes well like
a big baguette I want to have bread as
Katana style and also I want kroasan for
shuriken style like you have to like
long attack right and then for middle
age I want to have toast and like kind
of do like Circle floating
attack why what wait hold on why why the
bread how did you get to bread the one
fighter that could instant defeat me
maybe like a s uniform kind of costume
and like oh SAR uniform bread toast and
can I how did you make that connection
because the [__] [__] like putting
the bread in the toast in the mouth
thing and also I pray like AKA strip
this is like AKA strip game and you can
five with a bread actually baguette you
can attack somebody with baguette like
wait wait can me come back five a second
what is the akba stripping game yeah a
game called The Strip what the [__] is
that and you stripped uh you can't strip
normal people but they are vampires and
vampires are suceptible to like you know
sunlight right they're weak against
sunlights so you have to strip them to
reveal their skin and then they get told
by the sunlight yeah which you're trying
to kill the vampire by ripping off their
clo yeah but they're all hot chicks yeah
some are boys some more boys yeah okay
summer boys summer boys you know we
don't judge it's 2023 is it a good game
it is I do enjoy the ACT I even play the
sequel okay damn it's it's one of those
like just dumb fun games you know like
you don't take it all that seriously
it's like Saints Row you know like you
don't take that [__] seriously I mean
sounds fun it sounds fun yes it is I got
to check it
out no you're not yeah you're definitely
going to check it out I'm going to check
it out I'm going to check it out you
play it out on Twitch right I play it on
Twitch is it that bad for yes you can
you can I have okay that's fine then
yeah if I can play if I can play it on
Twitch it's not that bad right Conor's
Conor's idea of checking it out is just
going on Google and just looking at
being like all right I checked it out
you can a s on Twitch Soo what's wait
what's that oh oh it's boobs and all
some sometimes you know it's jiggle
physics the game uh Dead or Alive no
more than Dead or Alive more than Dead
or Alive it makes Dead or Alive look
tame it's there was an anime back in
like what 201 yeah I think you were the
big on pink think you seen you've
definitely seen this before seen around
the but one no no you going have to
narrow it down the one where they fight
with the butts on the platform that's no
yeah K and they had Pachinko and I did
the Pachinko promotion at Nik Niko
broadcasting because they needed girls
with big
boobs is that how they pitched to you
they're like Kaho we're looking for
someone with big boobs we think you're a
great fit his money fair enough I mean
hey I me Fair yeah as you said your um
do you get some of those stuff like
freelance or is that all manage like
agencies you're doing no freelance and I
have a website and they you that's
awesome I was going to say I was like d
after all the agency talk we talked
about she ain't going to go by the way
I'm still part of an agency yeah I just
hire managers and like it's not even
like their main job more side job so I
can just pay not so much and they can
just skim through some emails and then
yeah you're doing the smart yeah and
they can help me at the booth like at
conventions only when I need them yeah
oh [__] yeah awesome was like the
weirdest request like a TV show or like
some client has asked you to take part
of in in an event has there any been
like a weird request or anything like
that I mean for The Saga one I me we put
like a walking that's like a walking oh
the uh the the thing that counts steps
what are they called again spit on
pedometer pedometer yeah so we put here
or I forgot which part about around the
booths and just to
jiggle and to check the count that is
the most Japanese thing I've heard in my
life for what purpose oh yeah I forgot
maybe you win you win something I know
the these agency guys were like listen K
we need to figure out your jiggle per
minute uh ratio we got to see who's
number one yeah maybe if you get the
count right then you get the count then
you get something in the audience I
don't know I totally forgotten they like
is this trying to like be like some kind
of thing being like wow look how how
much of boobs jiggle yeah cuz that's s s
is all about the jiggle physics ah so
it's kind of Genius but also lowkey or
highy creepy as hell it has nothing to
do with
Pachinko I was like this is nothing to
do with Pachinko but this is this sounds
like a decision made in a boardroom with
a bunch of guys in a in business with
their dicks in their hands proba so
what's purpose of uh doing this we just
want to see some tits bouns bro that's
all at least from my experience working
a Japanese compan iies uh they love to
add things in last minute true they love
adding things on like little things
constantly you'll get that and they'll
be like we want to do this this you're
like okay why didn't we like write this
down and agree on it yeah yeah but
because I have done those things in the
past I have to be really careful now
that hey uh let's make sure like I have
rebranding and yeah yeah I don't do some
things anymore Andy make sure they know
that yeah like respect the boundaries
now that your position has changed right
yeah sure are most uh clients like chill
with that those boundaries or are some
of them like w we don't do you want to
do this crazy thing or yeah some
sometimes I just have we just have to
part ways obviously sometime they listen
or they pretend to listen but turns out
they're not listening at all so yeah jez
there are those people so you really
have to be careful well I think you've
been pretty successful with your image
change especially since the last time
you came on just seeing the amount of
different projects and seeing the
different uh more diverse yeah see the
diverse amount of things you've been
involved in it's youve definitely played
it smart as well in the fact that you've
uh not only like managed to kind of
Branch yourself out into so many
different like positions but you've done
it in a way where it's like a slow
transition so it seems way more natural
than like just suddenly being like yeah
so I used to do JV and uh now I'm in a
video game it's like you know it's like
it's it's not like that you know it's
like you just kind of slowly transition
people to be like oh yeah of course K's
in a game now that makes sense you know
so yeah you've you've you've played it
smart I think thank you yeah just try to
do gradually cuz I still I'm not going
to hide the fact I did that but the same
time I'm not going to keep pitching the
past like that's kind of I did this in
the P you're not going to keep waving
the flag right yeah totally is there
anything else you want to do in the
future that I you already seem to be
doing what haven't you done yet is there
like a dream you want to get there so
many different things I want to yeah I
want to be more involved in the project
from the beginning or more not just be
in it but not just in a creative
position I do actually enjoy that yeah
yeah and I have just that doing work all
the time and you know what whenever like
people try to get me into like a sex
conversation like now I'm like hey I'm
not having it I don't want it
anymore yeah I'm not interested in
having sex but I still read handai and
watch handai but it's like oh 2D staff
for me I need that 3D [__] dog
especially the co helps like hey I don't
want to you know exchange saliva or the
body fluid it doesn't feel safe like and
because I don't go out that much like my
immune system is so low like I I guess I
want catch something even from like hand
okay first yeah you go to Anime
conventions they are the most disease
ridden places in the world yeah so if
you that's one that's one step away from
Chernobyl get sick if you can survive an
Anime Con I think you can survive good
outside it's like you don't understand
if we kiss I will
die I have zero immune system when I was
in the industry I guess like I have to
kind of enjoy it or I think I was know
know doing the Persona and enjoyed all
the compliment my body and like hey I
want to I don't know I want to do like
sensor sys you yeah and then of course I
would smile all the time but now I
you're like yeah thank for no thanks say
that to your face H they do sometimes
even what wait I conventions a conven
well adult convention those are more
obvious obviously like one guy even in
Las Vegas like at at that convention
said like oh can I uh pay you and play
with your uh boobs later on and old guy
old old guys and they oh P you good and
like oh least strange
Amer that's average Las Vegas
resident that's completely illegal like
even in this country so like okay like
like okay I just don't understand first
of all the balls to just say that to
someone's face but like two just think
like what was he expect
you to be like well it depends on the
amount of money you're going to give me
like like [__] Jesus I mean I'm sure
there are like you know some women who
go who guest at those adult conventions
who you know maybe they'll say yes to
that right but like you can't just
[__] go around ask putting boundaries
yeah just respect the boundary exactly
also there's a less like direct way to
say it right as well and from the sounds
of it he was way too direct get to the
point yeah yeah I don't know I think
either way wherever he's working at
there is there is no way to say
it with uh you know class yeah of course
of course oh jeez the fact that he's
just asking that [__] to begin with you
know but I hope anime fans are
respectful they are very they would do
like H
hands
okay I love OPP is that out of do you
think that's out of respect or I believe
it's out of respect you know that is
that is the one thing I hope that never
dies in Anime conventions havan that
[__] is always hilarious Le try just
like a make a heart with them Le the T
do you do like this thing they do that
sometimes they do that yeah your friend
Zing like that yeah that's my favorite
yeah at least anime fans are like
adorably awkward you know yes that's the
thing yes yes yes yeah don't change
don't change your yeah don't change
anime fans stay NY keep the H
hand I like the H hand H hand's fun
oh have you noticed that last time you
guys are all wearing aarian and I was
just wearing I I love your dress ever
and oh the Rings too you always find I'm
so jealous
l oh [__] that's
sick where'd you get the dress oh this
is from a company called candy stripper
in Japan they're legit clothing company
it's just there's so many English word
you can find in Japan that sound really
weird okay I'm surprised even remember
the fact cuz like when you when you were
saying like oh yeah you you guys were
all wearing AA shirts last time I'm like
how do you remember that I do remember I
was like I feel kind of n no I'm just
wear M freaking M I feel so sad your
memory is crazy you always say stuff to
me and I'm like I forgot that 10 minutes
effort it happened I I don't remember
anything that's insane yeah even like
what every gar and cter underwear too
that's not going to be
shown what who are you matching that the
full set the full commitment yeah has
like too much
information yeah oh my God just needed
uh true AA fan right here yeah yeah I
really wanted to you know mention that
so you never you never answered earlier
what's uh what what anime do you want to
get nominated this year what what did
you put forward for like some of your
favorite anime this year I'm curious for
this season actually um oh for this
season okay um actually that show
started like last week of September so
it can kind of get in oh so it's like
I'm kindor I'm be about it because is it
right is it fair with just one episode
with show is Al one it's fre I love
mango fre so much such a good M oh my
God it's on Netflix right no [__] unfort
well I'm not sure Japan might be on
Netflix Japan saw on Netflix yeah cuz
it's on the west it's in crunchy roll so
that's all I know I want I want to see
like how it goes I guess like again like
the first episode was the longest
episode so yeah it was like an hour and
20 minutes I love hour first episode
anime get you into it I know CU you know
20 minutes on you just pulled out and
you're like a and [__] ended you
didn't say that about
ocean listen listen I liked the first
episode of ocean oo after that where it
lost me I thought the first episode of
ocean o was good and it was boring that
was even a shown on in cinema so wow
yeah yeah so this year I guess so
chainsa man
is for this year so they technically is
this
year those are big
ones uh and of course Ooa too like Ooa
uh I have been reading manga so it's not
there was no surprise for me but I
really like that the ambian and of the
kindfulness the the manga gone [__]
wild recently the manga recently I'm
just like ain't no way the manga's going
everywhere it is it's like it's losing
focus I think I know right thinka Saka
is just like I'm going to do what the
[__] it felt like that like two episodes
in it felt like I the beginning it's
like this season is probably We we
forgot about the whole mystery right
away we were like all right guys guess
we're going to ter house now yeah like
if you read the Manga recently aaak has
lost his mind like it's the like I I I
like I'm convinced he's just trolling at
this point like he just does I think
he's just trolling we don't want to
spoil anything but the same time like oh
what happened to this scene what
happened to this read ship and like wow
yeah yeah it gets wild yeah it's not too
bad I'm a little bit worried about uh
Kaiju oh yeah is definitely going down
the the poity and the cat for and then
anime hasn't started yet is the the
giant monster oh yeah like 30 something
year guy who just getting a prime time
after like obious prime time and he's
like joining this kind of self-defense
Force against uh kaijus he himself
become a Kaiju right the concept is kind
of interesting the concept is cool and
the first couple of volumes of the manga
were like really good hook first Arc is
really good yeah and then it's just kind
of slow yeah I agree it's kind of going
down a little bit happens with like so
many manga anime though the first one's
a banger and then they kind of like all
right well [__] actually the manga
recently that has in my opinion just
keeps going up is D oh yes that manga is
just it the peak it just keeps
peeking made yeah I read that for the
first time on stream other day it it is
wild it's [__] insane and to think
that that's his first manga that he's
ever made as well is like crazy yeah
it's it's crazy that we've had Dandan
and like hell's Paradise who are both
like assistants from the chainsaw man
Authur like what was going on in this
apartment going on in this office cing
ju juices you just like casually like
just creating prodigies like in his in
his office you know we see this with
other stuff that's happened though and
and different completely unrelated
different creative Fields across the
world I think when you get like a a
really big project a lot of people
worked on it often end up doing their
own really amazing stuff probably
because of the the environment they
learned so many important things yeah
for sure so I can imagine that the same
thing happens with maras yeah but I
think it's just like it's very rare in
the case of like fujimoto's assistants
like that it's l so far it's literally
been every single one of his assistants
have come out with absolute bangers that
are like unique in their own way like
cuz the problem with like a lot of
mangas Who start off as assistants of
other mangas is that they tend to kind
of like bite at the ankles of whoever
they were assisting right so like um one
I can think of is like saachi the
creator of Gintama his assistant uh um
the creator of SK dance oh SK oh yeah
was it was the assistant of s witch
watch right now yeah he's doing witch
watch right whereas like his stuff is
cool but when he first started off with
SK dance it was very obvious that he
took a ton of inspiration from G to the
point people were of calling it against
I'm aone whereas like Fujimoto assists
they making some wild [__] but none of
it is really like attach that much to
chainsaw man or any other of fujimo it's
all like they're just as wild yeah it's
all like wild [__] and I don't know if
that's because they all just happen to
be really wild people or if that was an
influence by Fujimoto cuz my God he like
if you read any interviews or any
stories about him as a person it's like
some of like he sounds like a maniac of
the weirdest [__] I've ever heard in my
life like you know what the
auo actually turned out to be a normal
guy according
to yeah I I I remember reading the story
about Fujimoto like the author of jsaw
man and he he was talking about his
childhood or something about how he had
like a childhood like a goldfish like
growing up and he talked about his his
experience when his goldfish died right
and he was like so sad when he was like
burying the Goldfish and he was like he
just never wanted to part from this
goldfish because it was his first pet so
you just [__] ate
[Music]
him that's prob yeah he got the idea of
eating somebody so important to you if
you watch the show
yeah so like when you hear that when you
hear that story right and you're like
okay I can see how that anecdote or that
experience influenced you know some of
the themes in like chainsaw man for
inance right so now when you read the
rest of Chainsaw man or like fire punch
or anything he's made you're just like
what stories behind this how did you
come up with this
[__] yeah it it Mak it made me realize
oh that's why chainsa man is way
chainsaw man is like his least weird
work in my like actually one of his
least weird Works in my I me what's the
saying again it's like a genius is just
an insane person with an
audience he he definitely strides that
line like perfectly
I guess look back was more sane I guess
look back was probably the most sane
one the most a lot yeah we just we're
just saying a lot wa what's your
favorite mango of all time uh 20th
century boys oh yeah easy which is why
I'm really really looking forward to
nowy sour Pluto like coming out this
yeah that's going to be sick coming out
this I mean yours obvious JoJo right uh
yeah I've read all of gejo actually I
haven't read uh part eight yet or nine
um cuz I just didn't get around to it I
don't know why party was yeah everyone
everyone I said party
and I'm so sad if I get into it I'm not
going to like it right I mean I really
really really liked gun a lot too cool
one of my
favorites uh except there's some weird
Parts but it was really
we so uh man berserk was also I feel
like berserk such a cop answer but it
was just so good I mean yeah I actually
started rereading berserk recently uh
because I had all the physical volumes
in my house in land the fairy [__] was
weird though I'm not going to lie it was
a little weird the fairy [__] yeah when
they just they get to the island with
fairies oh and you just like man he
played too many Idol
games oh let him cook though I don't may
we don't he cooked on the ark afterwards
that's fine okay yeah true you probably
read the most amount of manga I I guess
yeah um my all-time favorite if I had to
pick one it' probably be P right punp
for me is a love
like I think I think it's an abute
Masterpiece but I don't enjoy reading it
you know every time I reread it I think
like one where I think it's like
absolutely incredible and I love
rereading it every single time is
probably Fist of the Nora oh hul is
probably my alltime favorite like I've
reread that so many times and every
single time I'm like damn this thing is
so underappreciated especially in the
west like in Japan it's like a legendary
one thing I've struggle to really um
when when people talk about old manga
specifically is that it's hard to
separate the Legacy from like the actual
content and to know whether people are
are talking so fondly about it because
of what it once was or what it meant at
the time says the JoJo
fan JoJo's great still bro what are you
saying JoJo wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for f of the All Star no no no I
know but like it's like if it's like
when people are like uh when they what's
a really old one that people just talk
even it's dog [__] now
no I don't know like when people like
what I guess to lesser degree it's like
everyone I don't know yeah I guess
that's a like I don't know yeah just
Anime that everyone has watched in Japan
or Dragon Ball yeah and then like like
Dragon Ball is one of them where I would
say like Dragon Ball is is spoken about
a lot and it's very iconic but it's hard
to like actually be like all right what
is the actual like content here how do I
like all Nostalgia and everything away
right so like hwon noen has always been
one of those weird ones to me where I'm
like man I want to get into it but it's
hard to look past the way everyone talks
about it it's just more of a like it was
good or the Legacy I mean the memes have
definitely ruined it that's for sure
Myer [__] which is only ever said
once in the manga by the way and the
only other thing I know about it is that
every godamn Pinko place in Japan is
hton Oran which is like which I feel
like makes me not want to watch it
because I'm like why why that's how my
uncle became a
fan the
yeah every single Pinko place in Japan
is is hen and then there'll be another
anime or a that's because the age
demographic of people who are going to
these Pingo PS Now grew up reading H and
also like you remember the song So
vividly every time you listen to you are
shock like that [__] gets your blood
actually actually so [__]
true watch H can or read it I would read
it yeah reading just a vis is so
sounding and because you are fan of Jojo
I think you apprciate art backy too yeah
I think like the the anime was good like
I enjoyed it it was it was a good anime
adaptation um but the thing that really
stands out about Honan is just har Teto
the illustrator just his style yeah it's
so unlike
long 26 volumes I think I mean if you
can do one piece I'm like 50 volumes in
the one piece if you can do one piece in
JoJo you can do F isn't one piece long
uh isn't JoJo longer than one piece
yeah's longer than both well
Becky Becky's just I feels like it feels
like a fan cam for you like it doesn't
feel like like an actual story it just
feels like a fan-made story about you
yeah pretty much accurate also I
[__] memes dude the man this meal is
so good and then it's the the [__]
illusion I love that video that's become
a meme they're like anime fans eating
good and then it's you you making an
invisible Meal have you seen this yeah
it's [__] and he does the invisible
table
flip get him back in the manga the sex
scene like the first time sex scene it's
just like a fighting scene oh my God
that is my favorite it's just so funny
and then just yug just [__] hunched
over and just like eat
her John was telling me about the scene
where yujo has sex with a man but then
apparently the way he justifies it is
not being gay for whatever reason he's
like all other beings are are [__] to
me because I'm Yu yeah yeah yeah it's
like what like all other creatures on
this planet are below me so I can do
whatever I want what the [__] is
happening what is going on in this
manga this is like like if if like one
of those Alpha podcast men had like sex
they like no I wasn't gay wasn't gay ah
it was just I'm so out that's another
that's just destroyed the sexuality
debate with one
line you ask e how many genders are
there it's just like it's not a question
doesn't matter doesn't matter not going
to be even controversial that's that's
another manga artist that like I just
want to hear like anecdotes from how do
you how do you come up with give for a
drink with yeah right just love to sit
down just want to figure out like how do
you just come up with this [__] yeah
insane funny you mentioned samam dunk
earlier because that's my favorite manga
but I guess like we have I guess in Asia
it's like so loved it's like it's super
Lov I was debating between slam dunin
Fist and All Star for my favorite it's
like they're both out there for me hope
to get get more recognition in the west
and I was hoping that the new movie was
going to do that yeah unfortunately
because it was like CG even though I've
heard it was like still really really
good like if anime fans see CG now
they're
like I'm not watching dude in the I I I
go to the cinema a lot in Japan yeah I
swear for like three months straight it
was the only thing that was being played
yeah only thing like nothing else was
being played and if it other stuff was
being played it' be like nine showings
of Slam dun one showing of John Wick by
the way came out today and like what the
[__] is going on yeah I mean that's
that's the power man of Slam dong is
that like it's even to this day like
people are still rediscovering it like
newer Generations are rediscovering it
because they hear from the previous
generations right isn't that that uh the
famous spot where they go to take
pictures from the manga right it's just
it's just there it's just for a picture
yeah apparently that place has been like
they like they' interviewed a bunch of
people recently I saw on Japanese news
they were like yeah we just we wish
there wasn't so many tour coming to this
place espe from Korea and Mainland
China a lot of a lot of I didn't know
this made more money from the movie
there that's crazy that's it blows my
mind would you count as an old anime
that's a great question um
now cuz if you ask kids today you
recommend them like Spice and Wolf and
they'll be like that's an
old like we're getting in the old feel
in Pre 2000s and then I think pre 90s is
pre 9s is where I would I would say I
would say it's old cuz like I I realized
this the other day when I was like oh I
would consider like you know to in my
mind anything that's like 10 years or
below can be like That's a classic you
know but to me [__] like G Lagan still
feels recent even though I know it's
really not you know and then recently
like kill the kill just had its 10 year
anniversary I'm was like damn my life
man I remember I remember when that was
like
fresh hot I remember the day that she
was announced yeah yeah remember when
trigger saved anime because of K kill I
do trigger it still sounds kind of
new but yeah I think back in those day
when everyone just think of animation
company as Toho Cinema or toy too or
maybe tatoko Pro and that's the I guess
and that's
it if you can name more than that I
guess that's very new dude I remember
when like you know the the biggest like
Studio back in the day was like JC stuff
like not the biggest well JC stuff and
like uh Studio Dean was really big I
mean I remember when like I mean they
came back with free but I remember when
mad house was like the bar of production
IG production IG was up there they house
or I crazy no no they were separate yeah
but people from production IG started
trigger right no no no no no people from
gy oh gy started IG started Studio wits
that's it sorry yeah yeah God I
confusing I remember had a conversation
I went for lunch after I filmed
something at Studio trigger and some of
the staff just came and I mean because
obviously in Japan it's so hard to judge
people's
age man
they such a funny out of
context Asians
Asians and I swear this woman uh she
looked like 29 if she told me she was 29
i' believed her and she just casually
goes yeah I remember working on even
gallion I was like huh
what she's like what what are you what
you could just say that say I I remember
working on Evangelion or something I
wait so did you find out how old she was
actually I think I I I I jokingly I was
I think it came up we were all talking
about ages I think she said she was 50
something but my God she did not look 50
yeah I would have thought those anim
animator living conditions would have
sped run aging but apparently not I yeah
no it doesn't because you're inside the
whole time you you don't hit any of the
sun they told me I needed vitamin D that
I feel like that was a lie that's not
who who's they
people people told me I need Vitamin D
but everyone I know with the best
looking skin never leaves their house
what's up with that oh I I need Vitamin
D I don't know I I feel better with
vitamin
D I probably need it I I'm try salty cuz
I have white people's skin that's just
the British mentality you don't [__]
vam D you don't get any England anyway
it's always cloudy jealous of all three
of you with your you're going to have
amazing skin I already look like a like
a basketball that's used for too long
all right thank you very much
naby that's so much why you rocking the
sunglasses you want to
look I'm I'm I'm not trying to be cool
by wearing my sunglasses inside guys I
had an eye exam earlier today because I
was thinking about doing ICL surgery and
in case it looked like I was just
tripping balls no they just dilated my
pupils to check them uh so the lights
were very bright on my eyes this entire
podcast so we finally found some say
something corny as like my too bright so
I'm just going yeah some like rolling
[__]
yeah you know you just got to wear
shades yeah that's that's what Roland
said he was like when I asked him I was
like why do you always wear sunglasses
inside he's like oh it's just cuz my
future's too bright one time he was he
was balding and then because obviously
his whole thing is that he looks hot and
sexy and then he said like his response
to like the person who asked was like I
don't need hair that can't keep up with
me I was like [__] I should steal that
dude he has so he's like a oneliner
machine like my favorite one anecdote
was like you know cuz he's like a
massive anime fan right but like he is
like the some of the anime he's into
it's kind of questionable so so his
favorite show of all time his favorite
anime is DW
cubu all right which if you don't know
is an anime uh about a a teacher who
manages a elementary school girl
basketball team right so when you look
at the cover of this show pretty sus
right Roland loves that [__] right and
he said he mentioned that in a video
just very casually and and overnight he
lost like 10,000 Twitter followers yeah
like he even like States like he read
write Noel right yeah yeah yeah like
he's like proper degenerate right and in
response to that he tweeted out this
amazing tweet where he was like yeah so
after I said uh do Cub was my favorite
anime I lost like a bunch of Twitter
followers but I'm not going to look down
about it the only time I look down is
when I'm tying my shoes in the morning
oh wow another one nter another one and
I'm just like damn how I don't know how
he manages to act like such like
a what's the word just coincidential
cool guy that can notot yeah but just
like so like uh you know up himself and
just like so like yeah I'm the [__]
best but he's the one dude where I'm
like you know what you're right yeah you
go off if you do it you just got to
commit to it you know yeah totally and
that's the energy that he has so now you
have to do that with the sunglasses is
what I'm is what I'm getting at was the
whole work around that was the whole
work around for yeah
um already
fil he already
St say um yeah you can't say
um already fell already fell I'm trying
I'm trying to like cut out ums from my
talking it's very tough though I find it
impossible which is why I'm glad that I
do scripted content because I've
realized after 3 years of trash taste
sometime my brain just don't function
the way I wanted to and but like your
everyday life though like you you have
to talk yeah I know I know you have to
talk every day like how you just sound
so much more concise if you're never
uming and aring I just want to get to
the point like like where n r is at
where he's just he he's managed to just
cut out all you know cut out likes as
well yeah I need to cut out cut all
three of us are terrible with it
unfortunately my brain like a lot yeah
but it's just like such a good word you
know like it's such a good natural fill
word yeah now that I'm thinking about it
I'm I'm thinking so heavily about not
saying like and it's my brain it just
takes so much mental energy also I've
just realized that my brain is just not
concise at all some I I don't know if
this is a my brain thing but sometimes I
like I try to say a sentence and then my
brain just short circuits and I'm like I
was going to say a point yeah and I've
forgotten it mid-sentence I saw it's
just part of aging
process is it I I use no work getting
it's called early stage demena that's
what that is hey what's the Japanese
word you often say like it's kind of
like in
English
or it's words like that say something to
me I don't understand I'm
like say it again pleas you know even
when you're speaking Japanese right it's
very difficult in a in just a casual
conversation to not say things like Anor
and itff because it's such easy what
makes you sound more FLIR if you say it
in Japanese oh yeah you're a foreigner
all you have to do is just say a bunch
of anos and and you're like wow he's
he's been living here a long time
like no no the one that always impresses
the Japanese people where you're like
yeah
defu yeah but if you if you can't get to
that point just just throw in a couple
of and immediately you sound fluent I
know you have to be kind of ambiguous
speaking Japanese totally totally to
it's kind of like the same as
like yeah you don't you don't actually
it's not yes so no most of the time it's
not black in Hawaii yeah I've noticed
though when you speak English you don't
really say a lot of like likes and arms
and rs like you your English is insane
your English is very your English is
more concise than our English cuz I want
to have a good grammar and syntax like
when I'm speaking Japanese I don't care
like I'm native speaker like I can say
whatever but when you're speaking a
foreign language like a second language
then you want sound smart or you got
education so you want to put that into a
sentence so I I just CU obviously from
from knowing two languages and learning
a third I'm just so impressed that
you're able to your English is so
[__] good and you know all the slang
without ever having to live in in an
English speaking country I think is how
the [__] do you do that I love watching
TV shows that's crazy I I don't know how
you the whole reason I have VPN is to
watch some shows I hope like brooklyn99
I have to wait for like forever you
watch all brooklyn99 yes I am 99 damn
99 that's so fun wait so what so what
was some of like the shows other than
Brooklyn 99 that you used to like I I
[__] said it again what what were the
shows you use to you know get better at
your English or like learn all the uh
slang and stuff like that oh I am
watching Audi M and they talk fast and
they put a lot of words and that's a
Lego show so you can sound smart trying
to sound like that
oh yeah suits too but it was more
romantic
suit legal yeah I think show was like
friends you can learn
jokes I mean I I I watch suits and this
is like the ass I I kind of like it it's
kind of like a guilty pleasure for me
cuz it's like people do not the first
season or two was pretty good people do
not talk like this but it feels like
this is dialogue written by someone
taking a shower and can imagining like
the shower bottles like Harvey were
getting sued sue them back I don't care
what half of the dialogue and Suits is
just people just throwing a file down
and just walking off after saying like a
stinger and that that's like the
dialogue and suits and it doesn't
replicate reality but I'm like this is
the I'd like to think if I had an office
in Manhattan I'd be doing I'd behaving
like that for no reason just because you
can she feels like the right thing to do
yeah I watch I think a lot more comedy
because they talk a lot in comedy and
you can also learn the jokes you know
you can Lear the culture of Comedy there
true you should watch o Sunny in
Philadelphia oh yeah that's
what you'll learn
racism you you'll learn what not to say
you'll learn what not to say but you'll
have a good time doing it maybe yeah
always sunny is very good actually also
the show like the office us like I
onlyon watch the US version I haven't
watch the original version but the first
season is like what's the F like like is
it okay to like to joke about this kind
of thing but then it's grow on you like
you're going to start laughing the
character actually the first season is I
think it was not while received cuz it
was too much like the British
one in the UK we like a lot more like
cynical yeah like not not people not
being happy in our comedy we like it
goes wrong for our main characters yeah
so a lot of British comedy is more
really awkward and cringe deprecating
very much so um which I think where I
get a lot of my humor from which is why
in my videos I really like the kind of
cringe and awkward kind of like the pole
dancing and the stripper I I like it
when it's like really kind of
like it's hard to watch but you can't
look away and I think your viewers enjoy
that they actually tell me to just
please torture Conor
Moore tell you this yeah at the oh my
God like [__] him up please do more
please do more Jesus we want to see him
break on camera oh my God I don't think
anything could break me oh wow that's a
challenge well that sounds like a
challenge I don't think so I think I'd
be fine with anything wow but yeah I
think British yeah I mean British humor
and American humor are very very
different and it doesn't always
translate over uh especially when
there's been so many examples of
Americans taking TV British TV shows and
it just being kind of a disaster the
office is probably the only show that I
think they've translated over well and
that was after the first season and
that's just because they played to the
strengths of like American culture and
American humor as opposed to trying to
recreate I like the US office more than
the British one I think it's better now
as well yeah I think it's better but
that's because the British office only
has like two seasons yeah we we we don't
we don't make a lot of episodes TV shows
we kind like in Japan yeah we normally
do like six episodes or 10 Max we don't
really do more than that in a season
yeah I mean like everyone forgets like
Mr Bean only had like 10 episodes wow
was one season it was one season and and
a and a movie or two but like everyone
just assumes like oh yeah Mr Bean had
like 40 Seasons right it's like no
they're not going to try to make more
money like in easy
way that's
hows but considering the amount of
mileage they've gotten out of that one
bloody animated TV show Christ yeah EXA
cuz even in Japan sometimes we they
tried to make more episode for the anime
that was already good but they they want
to make more money and they kind of fell
like I wish let's not talk about boruto
yeah or all taxi the movie like yeah we
watch it together like oh damn I hope
like they didn't add that extra thing or
yeah which we went we went to go watch
the a taxi movie together and uh i'
watched all of OD taxi and I remember it
was pretty dialog heavy so I was like
okay I think I'll be fine to watch it
but it was just kind of like a
reash with like they were like we've
added so many new scenes and they only
added like Quenton Tarantino esque Diner
interviews where the characters would
give it was so weird it was very meta
the characters would be interviewed
about the events that were happening
like like a like like a mentary yeah
like a mockumentary yeah so they like
imagine if they just reframed all of OD
taxis a mockumentary and that was the
movie It's kind of what they did with
the Edward you don't know if you
remember the show it's about lesbians
and they added like a the final Arc like
a final season was so weird and I think
they're just making or they have started
like a new season after so many
years Sor which show is this uh the L
word the L the l oh I've never heard of
it yeah no I remember this one it was
probably the most successful Big Show
about um one of the big shows about J on
LGBT is that a British show no it's
American it's it's based in La I've
never heard of this one okay yeah I
think I'm
done no I have heard of it but I've
never watched it uh because it I
remember it airing when I was I think in
school it must have been a very very
long time ago at school University after
SE in the city there so many show the
city I did and I tried to get some
English words from it
like is this how all Western men are
supposed to be like yeah this is how
women talk in New
York yeah and they have a new season too
like after all years like a new season
yeah they had two movies and they have a
new season wow yeah yeah I didn't know
city was pretty big day city was pretty
big no it was it was massive I mean
itally never seen an episode it was a
cultural phenomenon but like so was
friends you know and does anyone still
talk about friends does anyone still
my sister's like a huge fan of that show
like constantly is rewatching friend
think apparently
so fans of the show will say yes um I I
was never really a fan of the show I
like some episodes that were kind of
funny but I mean it's just all right I
guess I'm GL I didn't like add more
episode they had Joey after that but you
know it ended so quickly yeah Joey
spin-off show yeah they did do that they
could try more but I'm glad they didn't
he's hosting Top
Gear he's not doing that anymore right
no he's not doing Top Gear is Top Gear
still the thing anymore I don't I don't
even know oh okay thing I also hope oh
sorry I also hope they didn't make code
gas more I
hope they did not
t watch
uh the Exile did you watch that was that
they had like the spinoff that was okay
cuz it was a spin-off that was set
during the time of the main or I can't
remember it was during but it was like a
side story so I'm like I'm good side
stories but they made a sequel to code
gas in the movies where it was Louch of
the Resurrection where L came back I
completely forgot about that and uh UND
did everything that was good about the
the end they brought back loose too and
like oh wow like why did you do that I
can't wait for the Death Note remake
where light gets
revived yeah yeah that's what I like
about the liveaction movie of this note
because they gave us the timate ending
which one the first one in Japan the
Japanese one right yeah that's that's
definitely the best one like L actually
winning against like KN and that's what
we needed and it's just end there what
did you think of the one piece live
action oh I've seen like bits like you
cannot avoid on social media you seen
the bits but I haven't to watch through
the entire scene but I'm glad that it's
being popular but I feel like the point
of having liveaction station is just to
bring more nomies to like anime and I
mean that's pretty much what it's done
you know that's pretty much what the one
piece live action has done totally that
every other live action has failed out
it doesn't really need to P fans but
it's great if you can well it's gotten
so many people who had maybe heard about
one piece but never had the courage to
like start the manga or start the
animator actually be like oh let me just
like take a little like quick taste test
of this and then I I have a lot of my
friends and and you know G and I'm sure
Conor does as well where like never well
yeah but like never never never had any
interest in watching anime or reading
manga or anything who watched the live
action one piece and was like I might
give it a go now oh cool you know so I
think that's I think that's a pretty
successful live action adaptation if it
does the opposite effect like say Dragon
Ball live action or attack on Titan live
action or any of those then it's like I
think you've just kind of failed as a
wish there was somewhere I could like
kind of Show anime people and be like
and hide all the weird [__] in the
closet for like 5 Seconds just watch
watch DEATH don't worry about the horse
Idol anime don't worry about don't don't
ask
hey man the whole side of anime was like
the entry level stu um um mus which is
really which is actually really well
animated actually a good
show yeah in terms of the idol stuff
which I'm not a fan of umu was actually
kind of good but it's such a weird
[__] thing to explain people don't
there's so much explain be stars to a
Nori imagine me being mature Utopia yeah
thinking about the same like yeah
imagine me being M kensei fan being like
okay so the latest Arc uh he gets
erectile dysfunction but actually that's
a that's a deep [__] character study
that goes somewhere and add to his
characters I swear to God I swear to God
guys I swear it was actually hinted that
in season one uh but everyone just
missed it I think more men could help
with
that help we need more representation
for men who can't get it
up I don't know you go to America I
swear every second commercial is an
erectile dysfunctional
commercial it's it's so weird where you
know they can do you have trouble
getting it up kind like that kind of
like that yes side effects may include
male pregnancy like like some [__] up
[__] you
know but yeah there is a lot of weird
sides to anime do do you think do you
want that weird side to disappear or do
you just want more people to accept that
that is a part of anime while also you
know acknowledging definitely the ladder
I think like no matter what the west or
like anyone says normally or not you
know when they look at some of the
weirdest [__] that comes out of the
anime world like Japan's not going to
stop doing that [__] right cuz obviously
they can do whatever the [__] they want
to stand out right but I think all I
want as an as a monger and anime fans to
just be like all right you don't have to
like this [__] but just leave it alone
yeah you know and if you want to check
it out then by all means go for it but
if you don't want to hey man that's fine
this's there's a, a one piece you can go
watch it's totally cool you know yeah I
I think there's there is a different
separation between it's it's like the
Shonen normal fans discovering the rest
of anime that become a thing uh and you
know I I like to me I always mentally
like separated oh this is the stuff I
meant to take seriously and this is the
stuff I'm like ah this is just [__]
weird although I say that but I swear
every year just just there seems to be
like a new title that is kind of hinted
at being like Oh there's an anime
adaptation that's coming out of this and
I read the title I go oh I I can see why
people think anime fans are [__]
weird you just read the title of some of
these shows and it's just like yeah you
know
what the latest thing you tweeted about
yeah that like people got my to my
sister or
something wait what hold on I'll I'll
pull it up I'll pull it up even that the
monk category I just mentioned earlier
is like there are some to get pregnant
or get pregnated on I tweeted out earli
this month uh I just said titles like
this remind me why people think anime
fans are weird the title is my little
sister is the best masturbation Mission
that's the one yeah what yeah uh
alternative title my little sister is
the best fap
material and I'm like okay look and I'm
like this is not a Doan why yeah this is
not a Doan and like it's getting an
anime adaptation I'm just like okay I
can see why normies think anime fans are
weird with this kind of [__] I totally
get it unless this is some kind of plot
for like youth in Asia I don't see how
this could well you know the term for
like a faty material in Japanese can be
okaz mean just like something that eat a
side dish like that's how you can eat
keep eating rice you know main thing our
sa is rice and you cannot just eat rice
you want something else like you steak
or something else so okaz is something
else that would encourage you to keep
eating rice yeah that's that's the
Japanese word for fat material so it's
not like in in Japanese the title
doesn't sound too bad because it's
something that aids you in
yourb that's literally where the word
comes from it's like you could you could
just eat white rice by itself as in like
you could just fat with just your mind
but why don't you have something on the
side that could help you with that it
works right that's where the word so it
kindor I mean I didn't I didn't think
that
part I can never eat rice I'm going to
think a come every time I eat
rice that's that's my favorite Japanese
word it's just it's just the whoever
came up with that word as a
genius well you learn something new
every day chat okazi so what's the
plot what do you
think so I have to explain
it it could be let's okay you know what
let's look it up can I can we can I hear
synopsis at least I it can't be that bad
right you're not be surprised by the
Emoto content because there's Oro
already right he loves Oro I mean okay
okay okay I will be that one em like Oro
Defender yeah I'm like that that was
that was what opened up the floodgates I
think but a lot of people watched that
and forget that it was like a cool um
story about otaku culture when back when
back when an environment where otaku
stories just weren't as mainstream as
they are now can we just have a hands up
who is an only child here again um hands
up I actually have a big
brother only child got that's why
gone I would just like to say when I
looked up the title of this show uh on
Google the f one of the first things
that came up was oremo episode
14 episode 14 yeah I actually I actually
can't find like a my anime list for this
show I don't think it's getting an anime
I think it's just getting a light novel
or a manga it's a light novel or a manga
I couldn't
imagine writing a light novel about
jacking off to your sister yeah how
bored do you have to be I mean if
there's a market for it it's it was like
interesting it was like very interesting
hearing Joey's interview with the reader
of healer author where you know respect
the hustle there he was like there was
the market for it and uh he provided the
material for the market you know yeah he
just all right here we go yeah yeah but
I sudden I think the market shouldn't
exist oh true it should be more Niche I
feel like we shouldn't have this Market
some some things I think you should
should be kept some things I think
should be kept in like the hentai kind
of category where oh my God I don't know
if I can read this synopsis bro oh no oh
no this this might have to be like
patreon how about how about M can B The
Selective moment all right Mudan good
luck all right I'm going to read the
synopsis bad it can't be how bad can it
be so I guess the synopsis is tall from
the perspective of the main character is
it a light novel by the way uh yes it's
a light novel it's a web novel oh God
all right this is the synopsis verbatim
Miu my own sister catches me to my
favorite sister erotic game she's always
cool straightforward and a bit salty but
for some reason she ends up helping me
no no in what way in what way this is
this is a hentai this is this is no way
this is a it gets worse it get worse I
began to on my little sister's
skin and have her touch it after a lot
of skinship now I can't bust a nut
unless I'm thinking of her
d That's a total h
that's the synopsis Dam you know like I
don't mind please censor that I don't
want that audio on the internet I don't
mind if something like this
exists if it's just like in the hentai
category but if it was a hentai
understandable but understandable but
this is a web novel yeah as in there
this is a web novel so like there's no
images you know has it been explained
that they're biologically not related
you know what I think that's the least
of they concerned cuz on or any for the
game they had to do that right they had
to be biologically unrelated for the
game PSP game really yes was a PSP game
p a PSP like visual novel for it yeah
okay which is not good did the anime
make that distinction oh no only for the
game because the game should be more the
mainstream like you beating one out oh
man it's so good the steps in so
actually for the game they actually get
married and have a kid or or two yeah in
the game not biologically related in the
anime they don't get married um well can
I it's a spoiler spoiler but they
do they have wedding the only that can
stand in the way the Japanese government
yeah they just they just kiss in the
enemy in the very end we would have
gotten away with it if this was
Alabama what the [__] was that other
thing you made me read what you made me
read one that was a Doan that was a Doan
what was that okay so that was like a
fan that's not canon that's not canon
that's not that's the whole point I
don't think the game is Canon either
right no I don't think the game is Canon
was this the or no I think it was just
for maybe somebody who older than 12
like it's a game so anybody can yeah I
guess but it's not allowed a game it's
still weird though look at least
domestic girlfriend had tact and and
plot and character develop I don't know
I I trust
you especially with those sunglasses on
I don't want
don't do not talk about next time you
talk about it you got to be smoking a
Cuban cigar let me talk about why to
girlfriend has Ted got understand the
thing about the domestic
girlfriend else anything else you want
to talk about is there is there anything
you want to shout out for people I don't
know well stop asking me when the new
content of me torturing corner is coming
because I don't want to spoil anything
two videos we've recorded two videos
that are coming out uh she got to find a
sponsor to cover the cost
yeah it's going to come up and on his
channel and Bre fine there and hopefully
you're going to have it one that's
reallyy fun like solo carrying Conor's
Channel I I told I was like you keeping
my channel alive I think without car my
channel would not be uploading I'd be
Twitch streaming so thank you I
appreciate it yeah you I mean we don't
have to tell you but go check out K
stuff links in the description go check
her out hey look at all these patrons
though do you see all these patrons on
the screen right now they're all they're
all floating up here point to your
favorite all laugh they heard synopsis
there's just one dude left on the
patreon oh my God but hey if you like to
support the show then head on over to
our patreon patreon.com trast also
follow us on Twitter send us your memes
on the subr and if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh thank you
Caro for coming back on to the show much
for bringing me back abolutely thanks
for back back on yeah always a pleasure
thank you and we'll see you guys next
week
[Music]
bye